la tensión entre china y taiwán crece
después de que al menos 10 aviones
chinos sobre bolas en este miércoles el
espacio aéreo taiwán es algo habitual
sin embargo el ministro de exteriores
habló incluso de guerra a work defense
nuestro ministerio de defensa está muy
decidido a protegernos
estamos dispuestos a defendernos sin
ninguna duda y lucharemos una guerra si
es necesario y si es necesario nos
defenderemos hasta el final nos
defenderemos hasta el último día
taiwán es visto por los analistas como
el principal conflicto que puede llevar
a eeuu y china a una guerra china
defiende que taiwán es una provincia y
aumentan movimientos estratégicos desde
eeuu siempre se han mostrado dispuestos
a defender la autonomía de taiwán y este
miércoles desplegaron unidades marítimas
en el estrecho de taiwán continuamos
volando navegando y operando en
cualquier lugar que permita la ley
internacional y usb age with you' es
john mccain llevan a cabo una rutina de
tránsito en el estrecho de taiwán sin
embargo a lo largo de los años se ha
mantenido un término medio autonomía
política
esa que excluye el control de beijing
pero sin llegar a ser independiente una
independencia respecto a china que si
reconocen 15 países como el pequeño
palau
si fuera el último hombre en pie
deberíamos estar con taiwán porque ellos
han estado con nosotros desde el inicio
igual sven with us from the big en algo
que ha molestado en china desde el
ministerio de exteriores defienden la
soberanía sobre taiwán un evento y como
todos saben el principio de una sola
china es un principio que respeta en la
mayoría de países en todo el mundo y con
hugo y bando los movimientos de china
son vistos de agresivos desde eeuu y
aseguran que tienen la intención de
suplantar les como potencia predominante
en asia